so this is really incredible so you guys
know chris ruffo from the manhattan
institute who i've had on the show many
times i think he's on on friday right
chris ruffo's going to be on the panel
on friday he has done an absolutely
incredible job of exposing what's going
on over at disney and what's going on at
many of these woke corporations he's the
one that leaked that original internal
video uh from the diversity equity and
inclusion group at disney where they
were talking about uh their secret gay
agenda or as they called it their not so
secret gay agenda and all of the ways
that they were trying to confuse kids
about gender well he found
video from a new disney show called
baymax and uh watch what they're subtly
doing here yeah men can have periods
here we go
excuse me which of these products would
you recommend
oh um
well
these are the tampons i usually use
thank you i prefer pads they're more
comfortable for me thank you i always
get the ones with wings thank you get
unscented and bleach free if you can
thank you yo my daughter loves these and
keys might be easier if it's our first
period these are really environmentally
friendly
what is going on here
what is going on here so i don't know is
baymax is he a robot or an alien or is
he an alien robot is he a boy or a girl
i have no idea but yes there was a boy
character a male character wearing a
trans shirt of course
and he says what kind of tampons he uses
what parent is letting their kids watch
this [ __ ] this absolute [ __ ] they are
coming for your children's brains is
that not enough to get you to wake up to
woke ness
uh here is rachel levine who is the guy
in charge of uh what is he is the deputy
health secretary uh and uh very excited
to talk about
kids chopping off their genitals
gender affirming care is life-saving
medically necessary
age appropriate and a critical tool for
health care providers
as a pediatrician when it comes to
making sure kids are healthy and happy
i know how important care that affirmed
someone's true identity can be
okay first off there's no science behind
what he just said right there that
person also lived their life their
entire life as a man until a couple
years ago right about five years ago
that was a dude with a wife and kids and
the whole thing now dresses up like a
woman and and we are supposed to pretend
that there's any science between gender
affirming care also think about the way
they use the words backwards gender
affirming care if you were affirming
someone's gender wouldn't you be saying
oh you are a biological girl we will do
everything we can to affirm your gender
you may have some feelings within you uh
that are not connected to your
biological gender but we are going to
either disaffirm that or when you become
an adult then you can live the way you
wish to live okay that would be okay but
they are they're calling gender
affirming care it's the reverse of
gender affirming care they it's gender
confusion care is actually what they are
doing if you are listening to rachel
levine that guy who is he i mean that is
a guy he lived his whole life as a guy
that is it i could lose i guess we were
off youtube probably today we had a good
run it was a hell of a run you know but
if if they take me off you know what
i'll do you know what i'll do
i'll come out as trans and then they
will have taken off a woman off youtube
that's what we're gonna do it's just you
guys get it it's all so ridiculous and
everyone gets it everyone can see
through it it is pure nonsense it is not
affirming to chop off a young child's
genitals it's not